hello readers today i'd like to talk
about differences
in point of view in literature when we
analyze the perspectives of storytellers
whether that's a point of view character
an omniscient narrator or a narrator
that attaches closely to multiple
perspectives
we can understand the way that an author
is controlling the flow of information
who knows what when and what does that
tell us
a writer can control which characters
have access to information
and they can control what access you the
reader or the viewer have to information
too
and the information you have and the
information the characters have
helped develop our perspectives within a
story
conflict between characters can come
from a difference in perspective
in avatar the last airbender the
character of prince zuko
is consumed by his desire to capture the
avatar
as he feels that this will end his exile
and restore him to a place of prominence
at his father's side
his uncle iro however understands based
on many years of hard experience
that zuko's father is a cruel man who
never intended to take his son back
ira only wants to keep his nephew safe
and this difference in perspective
generates a lot of conflict between the
two of them
the show slowly reveals ira's
perspective over time
whereas we as viewers know what zuko
wants and why
almost immediately in
fiction that kind of information
asymmetry between the storyteller
the characters and the audience leads to
something called
dramatic irony you're watching a play or
a tv show or reading a book
and you the audience the reader knows
something that the characters don't
this is possible because especially in a
visual medium
the audience has a different point of
view than the characters do
we can see things they don't see this
difference in point of view is what
allows
tension suspense and jokes
remember irony is just the difference
between expectation and result
it can be leveraged to achieve anything
that uses the mechanism
of surprise i don't want to belabor how
jokes work literally nothing is more
boring or unfunny than explaining jokes
so let's use
suspense as our example imagine a very
low-stakes villain
the cheeseler who goes around pranking
people by balancing
buckets of cottage cheese on door frames
you go through the door
blam you get cheesed so i want you to
imagine a scene in which we see the
cheezler booby-trap the protagonist's
door
with a bucket of cottage cheese nobody
else in the story is around to witness
this
after all the cheeseler stands alone and
now we see our hero in tamika
she's walking down the hall with such
confidence blindly unaware of the cheesy
threat that awaits her when she opens
that door
we cut back to the cheese it's still
there oh no oh no tamika
[Music]
do you see what i'm doing here do you
see how this generates suspense
you the viewer knows something the
character doesn't know
the difference between her point of view
and your point of view
generates tension this is something that
writers do on purpose
this tension this dramatic irony draws
us in because it's very
satisfying to see it resolved we know
that there's that possibility of tamika
getting splatted with cottage cheese
but what if tamika at the last moment
kicks open the door the cheese bucket
drops and tamika catches it neatly
thank goodness she saw the door was
slightly ajar
and put it together the tension is
resolved as the gap closes between
what tamika knows and what we know
when characters resolve interpersonal
differences it's through an alignment
of their points of view that's what
brings us to resolution
the difference between two points of
view can be reconciled
and that too is a way of relieving story
tension
now i'd like to counsel you against
making blanket statements about specific
genres of work like
sure a first person story could limit
the flow of information
because we're perceiving a story through
the senses of the point of view
character
but in your analysis of that story be
sure to get
specific how does that specific
character in that particular situation
see events why does the author show us
the readers
information that that character doesn't
get to see
asking yourself questions about those
differences in perspective
between the narration and characters
between two or more characters
between the text and the reader will
make it easy for you to analyze the
impact of those decisions that the
author made
and now i'm going to go walk my dog i
will see you all next time
you can learn anything dave it out
all right
curse you cheeseler